souvenirs les plus marquants il me
viennent de séjour ou ma vie a changé
je suis marié à la plus célèbre
journaliste au monde et fils ou
complètement perdus ils ont besoin de
savoir la vérité j'élève deux
adolescentes et superman mais j'essaie
de rendre cette planète plus sur
toi tu fais des trucs de superman et moi
je vais faire mes tweets de loxley si
jamais quelqu'un découvre qui je suis ça
va tout changer
vous n'êtes vraiment pas comme les
autres
porte est devenu superman et moi je sais
qui
on va devoir surveiller de près et et
pouvoir
vous avoir cette crypte de vie devant
créer l'armé
il se passe quelque chose de terrible on
trouvera les réponses ensemble
[Musique]
superman hello his votre nouvelle série
inédite mardi à 21h10 sur tf1